Speaker 1: Well, it's been an incredible
weekend of news. Some good, some bad, some
almost completely unbelievable, which we will get
to. But I want to start today with an incredible
piece of reporting in Rolling Stone from
Hunter Walker, where Hunter has put together a
story after story of the January six Trump
rioters meeting with Republicans with Trump
White House staff. And it is all coming
together to paint a very specific picture,
which is that there were so many people involved
in this thing, and mere expulsion from the House
of Representatives would not be enough. But
we'll get to that. We'll get to that. I don't
want to get ahead of myself. Let's start with
the Rolling Stone piece. Hunter Walker writes
exclusive Jan. six protest organizers say
they participated in quote dozens of planning
meetings with members of Congress and White House
staff. Two sources are communicating with House
investigators and detailed a stunning series of
allegations to Rolling Stone, including a promise
of a blanket pardon from the Oval Office. This
if even five percent of this is as described,
this is historic. Historic. Let's look as the
House investigation into the Jan. six attacks heat
up. Some of the planners of the pro-Trump rallies
that took place in Washington, D.C., have been
communicating with congressional investigators
and sharing new information about what happened
when the former president's supporters stormed the
U.S. Capitol. Two of these people have spoken to
Rolling Rolling Stone extensively in recent weeks
and detailed explosive allegations that multiple
members of Congress were intimately involved
in planning both Trump's efforts to overturn
his election loss and the Jan. six events that
turned violent. Rolling Stone separately confirmed
a third person involved in the main Jan. six
rally has communicated with the committee. This
is the first report that the committee is hearing
major new allegations from potential cooperating
witnesses. While there have been prior indications
that members of Congress were involved. This is
also the first account deal detailing their
purported role and its scope. The two sources
also claim they interacted with members of
Trump's team, including former White House
Chief of Staff Mark Meadows, who they describe
as having an opportunity to prevent the violence.
Look at the scope of this. The two sources, both
of whom have been granted anonymity due to the
ongoing investigation, described participating in
dozens of planning briefings ahead of the big day
when Trump supporters broke into the Capitol
as his election loss to Joe Biden was being
certified. Here we go. I remember Marjorie
Taylor Greene, specifically, the organizer,
says. I remember talking to probably close to
a dozen other members at one point or another
or their staffs. For the sake of clarity, we will
refer to one of the sources as a rally organizer
and the other as a planner. Rolling Stone
confirmed both sources were involved in organizing
the main event aimed at objecting to the electoral
certification, which took place at the White House
ellipse on Jan. six. Trump spoke at that rally and
encouraged his supporters to march to the Capitol.
It then gets wild. Along with Green, the
conspiratorial pro-Trump Republican from Georgia
who took office earlier this year, the pair
both say the members who participated in these
conversations or had stopped top staffers join
include Representative Paul Gosar from Arizona
Representative Lauren Boebert, Mo Brooks, Madison
Cawthorn, Andy Biggs and Louie Gohmert. It's a
who's who of the most extreme members of Congress.
We would talk to Boebert Team Catherine's team
go TSA's team like back to back to back to back.
Says the organizer. Now look at this allegation.
GOES-R, one of the most prominent defenders of
the rioters, allegedly took things a step further.
Both sources say he dangled the possibility
of a blanket pardon in an unrelated, ongoing
investigation to encourage them to plan the
protests. Our impression was that it was a done
deal. The organizer says that he'd spoken to the
president about it in the Oval in a meeting about
pardons and that our names came up. They were
working on submitting the paperwork and getting
members of the House Freedom Caucus to sign on
as a show of support. The organizer claims the
pair received several assurances about the blanket
pardon from Gosar. I was just going over the list
of pardons and we wanted to tell you guys how much
we appreciate all the hard work you've been doing,
GOES-R said. According to the organizer, the rally
planner describes the pardon as being offered,
while quote encouraging the staging of protests
against the election. The allegation is pardons
dangled in exchange for organizing the Jan.
six riots. Can you imagine I would have done
it either way with or without the pardon, the
organizer says, I do believe in this country,
but to use something like that and put that
out on the table when someone is so desperate.
It's really not good. Business goes out. Office
did not respond to requests for the story.
Rolling Stone separately obtained
documentary evidence that both sources
were in contact with GOES-R in Bohbot. They
don't seem to be lying about that part.
We are not describing the nature of that
evidence to preserve their anonymity.
And it every paragraph, every paragraph is
crazy. These specific members of Congress
were involved in the pro-Trump activism
around the election certification. Brooks
and Cawthorn spoke with Trump at the Ellipse
on January 6th in a speech at that event.
Brooks, who was reportedly wearing body armor
which but why do you do that unless you suspect
you might need it? Declared Today, today's the
day American patriots start taking down the names,
taking down names and kicking ass. GOES-R Green
and Boebert were billed as speakers at the wild
protest, which took place on January 6th at the
Capitol. Nick Dyer, who is Marjorie Taylor Green's
comms director, said she was solely involved in
planning to object to the electoral certification
on the House floor. Spokespeople for other
members of Congress, who the sources describe
as involved in the planning for protests, did not
respond to requests for comment. It seems folks
as if individuals here are lawyering up and
being very, very careful, very, very careful.
By the way, we have video of some of these people
admitting they were involved in planning. Now they
would say, Well, we just planned a procedural
objection. It's becoming harder and harder to
believe that that's the limit of it. Here is
Marjorie Taylor Greene coming out, coming out
back in December of 2020. Listen, man, she's
Speaker 2: finished with our meetings here at
the White House this afternoon, where they had a
great planning session for our Jan. six objection
Speaker 1: at the White House. Planning for
January six now, of course, she'll say well,
but we weren't planning for violence.
Speaker 2: No, we aren't going to let this
election be stolen by Joe Biden and the Democrats
while President Trump won by a landslide. Call
your House rep. Call your senators from your state
Senate. Make sure they're on board. And we already
have a lot of people engaged. OK, stay tuned.
Speaker 1: So this is one of the biggest
revelations about the Jan. six riots. It's really
incredible work by Hunter Walker, who researched
and wrote this piece for Rolling Stone pardons,
dangled people who we already believed were
involved or admit to have been coordinating events
that day, with the White House allegedly doing far
more than that. And it's, you know, all of these
folks are playing their roles. The GOES-R pardon
never trust a promise or an intimation from
these people, especially if they're asking
you to do something they wouldn't do, which
GOES-R had no interest in going to this thing.
But GOES-R was certainly interested in encouraging
others by dangling a pardon which never came.
Trump, Trump told his supporters, Let's go to the
Capitol right now. He went and then watched on TV.
But he said, We're going down Pennsylvania
Avenue. This story, this explosive story
was nowhere on Fox News this morning. Nowhere
on FOXNews.com. Maybe they'll mention it
at some point, but like it didn't
even happen, is their approach so
far? What should the consequences be?
Well, let's talk about what AOC says.